400 migrantes detenidos en la última
semana y un discurso de odio que cala
cada vez más en la sociedad tunecina
Esta es la razón de las numerosas filas
de marfileños frente a la embajada de su
país en túnez piense repatriados antes
de seguir recibiendo malos tratos
algunos de ellos Perdieron su
alojamiento le pagan los arrendatarios
nos echaron la gente nos golpea y nos
maltrata Para estar seguros preferimos
venir a nuestra embajada para
inscribirnos y regresar a Costa de
Marfil
a los desalojos inexplicables y la
violencia se suma la presión
gubernamental a los comercios
administrados o creados por migrantes
subsaharianos peluquerías y restaurantes
informales cerraron sus puertas el
creciente racismo en túnez hacia la
migración proveniente de países como
senegal Guinea República democrática del
Congo y Camerún se evidenció en
declaraciones del presidente el 21 de
febrero saiet señalado autoritarismo por
ong afirmó Sin evidencias que una
empresa criminal para cambiar la
composición demográfica del país con el
objetivo de convertir a túnez en una
nación exclusivamente africana y es
dibujar su carácter árabe musulmán de
esta forma el presidente tunecino
justificó la adopción de medidas
urgentes a nivel diplomático de
seguridad y militar para frenar la
migración irregular
comunicado de prensa que aparece en la
página web de la presidencia tunecina
realmente desencadenó Una psicosis
dentro de la comunidad subsahariana nos
sentimos abandonados y expuestos a la
condena popular generada por un discurso
de Odio que ya venía gestionándose en
las redes sociales
es uno de los pasos más transcurridos
por migrantes subsaharianos con destino
a Europa tan solo 150 kilómetros separan
a las costas tunecinas de La Isla
italiana de lampedusa
[Música]